Після повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну країни Європи кардинально змінюють своє ставлення до активів росіян.
Російські олігархи рясно відмивали гроші через європейські лазівки,
і тепер уряди цих країн намагаються перекрити їм кран.
Щоправда, критики закидають, що поки що робиться недостатньо.
Одна з таких країн - Великобританія. Досі Лондон був вельми лояльним до російських грошей.
Російським олігархам легко було знайти банкірів, юристів та брокерів, готовий співпрацювати.
Гроші, зокрема, можна було легко відмивати через складні схеми з офшорними трастами.
За оцінками британської влади, щорічно через Великобританію проходить
близько 100 мільярдів фунтів стерлінгів незаконного фінансування.
Після вторгнення Росії в Україну у британському парламенті заговорили про необхідність законопроєкту про економічні злочини.
Він має суттєво ускладнити життя багатіям, які прагнуть приховати свої статки в Об'єднаному Королівстві, зокрема через купівлю нерухомості.
Протягом останніх 20 років Великобританія була слабким місцем для брудних російських грошей.
Росіяни приїжджали сюди зі своїми грошима, їм подобається верховенство закону тут,
їм подобаються права власності, і їм подобається, що ніхто не ставить жодних питань.
Разом із Біллом Браудером їдемо на Ітон-сквер - одну з найбільших площ Лондона у фешенебельному районі Белгравіа.
Це місце ще називають "Червоною площею".
П'ятикімнатна квартира тут коштує понад 20 мільйонів євро.
І ніхто не питає, хто справжній власник.
За оцінками місцевих борців з корупцією, російські олігархи, пов'язані з Путіним,
останніми роками інвестували майже 2 мільярди євро лише у нерухомість.
Є підставні компанії, трасти, офшорні трасти, номінальні особи та довірені особи,
і всі вони старанно працюють, щоб захистити справжнє право власності на цю нерухомість.
"Лондонград" - так уже дехто почав називати столицю Великобританії через те, що тут живе багато багатих росіян,
і далеко не всі з них заробляють собі на життя чесною працею.
Британський парламент нарешті взявся за закон, покликаний приборкати корупційний потік грошей із Росії
та зруйнувати складні структури власності.
Але це лише перший крок у боротьбі із відмиванням грОшей, вважають експерти.
Одного лише законодавства недостатньо.
Воно повинно реально працювати, а це необхідно належним чином профінансувати.
А нині відбувається настпне: Національне агентство боротьби зі злочинністю
недофінансується протягом десятиліть.
Тому зараз необхідно, щоб правоохоронці отримали відповідне фінансування.
Насамперед я хотів би, щоб 100 олігархів потрапили до списку санкцій і їхнє майно було заморожене.
По-друге, я хотів би, щоб було виявлено і після цього заморожено їхні активи.
І по-третє, я хотів би, щоб усі російські банки, а не лише кілька з них були відключені від системи Swift.
Ще одна країна Європи, яка славиться своїм "нейтральним" статусом,
також активніше береться за боротьбу з відмиванням грошей російських олігархів.
Швейцарський Цюрих - одне з найдорожчих міст у світі.
Не в останню чергу - через російських олігархів, які залюбки вкладають сюди свої гроші.
Рудольф Ельмер колись був провідним банкіром у цюрихському банку Julius Baer.
Сьогодні він - один з непримиренних критиків цих фінансових інститутів і відомий як інформатор Wikileaks.
У Швейцарії зберігаються величезні фінансові активи,
адже банківська таємниця захищає олігархів.
У нас діє суворий закон про таємницю вкладів.
Уряд, політики та судові органи підтримують це, бо це одне з найважливіших джерел прибутку Швейцарії.
Але на тлі війни Росії проти України на Швейцарію почали потужно тиснути інші країни Заходу -
аби влада країни долучилася до санкційних заходів.
У результаті Берн підтримав санкції - мовляв, російські олігархи більше не матимуть доступу до своїх активів у Швейцарії.
Але Ельмер налаштований скептично.
Швейцарія зволікала з введенням санкцій.
Це дало олігархам достатньо часу, щоб перевести свої кошти в інше місце.
Приховування походження грошей - давня традиція у Швейцарії.
Це означає, що фактичний власник маскується за допомогою трастів на Кайманових островах,
офшорів, підставних компаній або інших подібних схем так,
що часто ви просто не в змозі дізнатися, кому насправді належать ті чи інші гроші.
Асоціація швейцарських банкірів відкидає це звинувачення, заявляючи,
що санкції можуть бути дотримані повною мірою.
Важливо розуміти, що санкції зобов'язують банки повідомляти владу про російських клієнтів.
Банківська таємниця ніколи не буває абсолютною.
На неї можуть впливати юридичні зобов'язання щодо надання інформації.
Це стосується і нинішніх санкцій.
Російські "Газпромбанк" та "Сбербанк", представництва яких є і тут, у Цюриху, звільнені від санкцій.
Це дозволяє країнам ЄС, таким, як Німеччина, як і раніше, купувати через них російську нафту і газ.
Це викликає дедалі більшу критику у швейцарському суспільстві.
"Сбербанк" у Цюриху закрив свій логотип та опустив жалюзі на вікнах, побоюючись протестів.
Неурядова організація Public Eye вже давно критикує російські банки.
А тепер тут стверджують, що ці банки відіграють вирішальну роль у війні, розв'язаній Москвою.
Це, звичайно, є вагомою частиною військової каси Путіна.
Він розраховував на неї з самого початку, а також припускав, що ці гроші принаймні продовжуватимуть надходити.
Ми говоримо про мільярд доларів щодня, 80 відсотків яких надходить зі швейцарських торгових майданчиків.
Один із центрів міжбанківської системи Swift знаходиться зовсім поруч із Цюріхом.
Наразі він знаходиться під посиленою охороною через побоювання диверсій з боку Росії.
Разом з тим Рудольф Ельмер не думає, що повне відключення Росії від Swift буде настільки драматичним для Росії.
Існують різні способи обійти це, наприклад, через угоди безпосередньо між компаніями,
банківські холдинги, за допомогою обхідних торгових шляхів, а також бартерних угод.
Варіантів багато, і не варто забувати, що сьогодні через санкції бізнес навколо платіжних операцій став ще прибутковішим.
Ще одна дружня до російського бізнесу європейська країна відреагувала
на вторгнення російських військ в Україну арештами майна олігархів.
Аби збільшити тиск на президента Росії Володимира Путіна,
Італія почала конфісковувати суперяхти та іншу розкішну нерухомість у мільярдерів із санкційних списків.
Італійська влада конфіскувала яхти та вілли на суму понад 143 мільйони євро.
Вілли російських олігархів знаходяться у мальовничих місцях -
Тоскана, Сардинія, Лігурійське узбережжя та озеро Комо.
Італійська фінансова поліція захопила в порту Сан-Ремо суперяхту "Лена", яка належить Геннадію Тимченку,
наближеному до Путіна олігарху.
Конфіскували також 65-метрову яхту "Леді М" російського мільярдера Олексія Мордашова.
Судно має шість апартаментів і оцінюється в 65 мільйонів євро.
І, напевно, найбільший улов італійської поліції -
арешт мегаяхти російського олігарха Андрія Мельниченка.
Яхта була пришвартована в порту Трієста.
Ця суперяхта вважається однією з найбільших приватних парусних моторних яхт у світі -
143 метри завдовжки і 25 метрів завширшки.
А її вартість сягає близько 500 мільйонів євро.
Арешти майна цих олігархів відбулися після запровадження санкцій ЄС.
9 березня до списку персональних санкцій ЄС додали 160 осіб.
14 з них - олігархи та бізнесмени, а також члени їхніх сімей.
Решта - депутати Ради Федерації, які визнали так звані "ДНР" та "ЛНР".
А цього тижня Євросоюз запровадив четвертий пакет санкцій за війну Росії проти України.
До санкційного списку внесли ще 15 фізичних і 9 юридичних осіб.
Серед них - російський олігарх Роман Абрамович, гендиректор "Рособоронекспорта" Олександр Міхеєв,
гендиректор 1 каналу російського ТБ Костянтин Ернст.